bubbling gotcha so what I'm more
concerned about is our enforcement now
in terms of
many years several years ago we just
chose to make tobacco
enforced by The Liquor Commission along
with because the liquid commission was
already going into these convenience
stores and regulating the sale of the
products at that spot so that
theoretically my concern is that so are
we passing this theoretically now is our
is our Liquor Commission enforcement
in terms of enforcing the current
statute related to tobacco
and smoking products because I know we
put piping and we put those little
vaping stuffs in with that statue that's
all together are they going to be
enforcing this new section
there's nothing in the bill that
specifically requires them to enforce
this we have had conversations with the
Liquor Commission I don't know if
they're here
um it would be helpful if they if they
were here to answer those questions
um but my understanding is that to the
extent that they have access to licensed
facilities for tobacco uh and liquor
with this prohibition they could also uh
enforce
um the law after this I guess would it
be the 439a is that in there is that
picked up by the reinforcement division
now
439a the hemp law sits under the
Department of Agriculture uh uh grants
of statutory Authority again my
understanding is the filter commission
has brought authority to uh enforce
state law generally and so this
prohibition or this Clarity that these
products were never intended to be
illegal would be caught up by liquor
commissions General Authority uh to
enforce state law in a general way okay
okay
any other questions to the committee yes
representative Sullivan thank you um
just
you you said you're not sure if they are
actually iding people who are buying it
are they supposed to like is the law on
the books now that you have to be 21 to
buy this or is it no so there's no law
on the books for a 10 year old to walk
in and buy it if they felt like it yes
all right
this legislation saying prohibiting it
this would prohibit the sale to anybody
so what do you mean an ID involved this
is prohibiting that sale of these
products to anybody period that is
uh thank you my question has to do with
clarifying the wording there's some
wording in here that I'm not clear on
for instance it says that
THC greater than 0.03 percent
and maybe you're not the right person
for me to ask this but the law talks
about 0.3 percent that hemp is defined
as a variety of cannabis that's point
three percent so it's 0.03 percent a
mistake the second thing is that Delta 9
THC comes from can be developed from a
cannabis variety but cannot be developed
from a hemp variety that meets the 0.3
percent so there's there's terminology
in here that's conflicting and I'm
getting very confused uh sure again uh
Mr Simon behind me will be able to
provide more detail however 0.03 is the
correct amount of legal THC in
industrial hemp products and secondly
um from those plans from industrial hemp
legal Industrial Hemp plants
which are legal because that they have a
THC level of under 0.03 percent
they can extract
CBD can be extracted from those legal
Industrial Hemp plants that are under
the THC level and the CBD then the
chemical that is extracted can be
converted chemically synthetically back
into Delta 9 THC which is the active
ingredient in cannabis it can also be
synthesized into Delta 8 THC it can also
be synthesized into many other THC
cannabinoids that appear in cannabis
plants in small doses and novel
cannabinoids that do not appear in
I must say I treated that that 0.03
percent is like our non-alcohol beer it
says on it has to be less than 0.05
percent so there was some saying some
some products just have can't help it
have something in it some grain of it
but it has to be this de minimis number
to say it's got to be less than that so
it's a very reduced form of hemp exactly
I see okay yeah representing Gibson uh
thank you Mr chairman
um
just so unclear uh I've seen on on store
counters products labeled CBD and
product label THC I honestly
don't know that much about what they do
and I have actually never purchased any
of them
um uh but my question is this statute
would completely prohibit the sale of
the THC products but would allow the CBD
products is that correct
that is correct CBD products gen are the
general difference between CBD and THC
is that CBD is non-intoxicating
THC is the product in t in in cannabis
that is intoxicating so yes you're right
this bill would do nothing with regard
to Legal CBD the federal government has
legalized CBD as a as a as a as a
product but not THC thank you
okay representative Ammon thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking our questions
um so we're talking about this 0.03
percent what percentage THC are being
sold in products around the state do we
know uh has there been any analysis done
uh we can only go by their labels
uh I believe Mr Simon has passed out
um emailed the committee um there's an
image here of a label that was purchased
in in uh New Hampshire and 92 THC
um
10 milligrams of thcp
uh so we're talking about labeling which
is
astronomically higher than the 0.03
percent
representative Waltz
thank you
can you tell us exactly what are these
products that don't have like an age
minimum I mean is it are they edible
products is it uh like yeah you want to
these products they have they're a range
of products including uh Vape cartridges
um okay so for Vape as a question was
already yeah so Edibles uh cartridges
and and perhaps others tinctures
any form that they can sell it they will
right but isn't there a age like they're
offer cigarettes isn't there an age
that's the problem there's no regulation
that's what we're about to pass here and
what we're going to pass is something
you will like we're Banning it all
together we're not even talking about
age here we're Banning it all together
nice
thank you thank you Mr chairman you're
enforce
enforce so these
these laws prohibiting the sale
look very good or right
sound reasonable but it's always the
enforcement so I think we said it was
The Liquor Commission but we certainly
can take it up and subcommittee but I
think we might want to make a reference
to make sure that the Liquor Commission
and they're looking forward and then how
would they do that and what they do it
now right now when they come in and they
expect what's on the shelves yeah
but more importantly obviously they're
they're concerned about the sales and
who's you know whether you're old enough
and qualified to buy the cigarettes
with the way that the statue was today
but in this case that yeah they would be
looking on the shelf and and and telling
the uh vendor to remove something remove
a product so uh appropriate uh
enforcement would be critical to this
absolutely okay thank you don't want to
pass something that's not enforced to to
declare if I may to clarify my testimony
was not that the Liquor Commission was
on board my testimony was at the Liquor
Commission is aware of this bill
um and
we wish they were here right okay
so you know it was not asked for a
question yet
representative McAleer
thank you so my understanding that a lot
of these products are on the shelves and
gas stations etc etc
and I noticed and so those will be
illegal
I noticed that this
uh bill would be active after 60 days
that tells me that these people would
maybe do a fire sale to get rid of all
this stuff because they did if they
don't they have to throw it away would
it make more sense to make this bill be
effective immediately so that that
doesn't happen
the Department of Health and Human
Services doesn't have an opinion yes it
it might um but the Liquor Commission to
the extent that they uh choose to
enforce this may need
um some time to ramp up you know any any
kind of enforcement
um 60 days is a standard yeah so this
this question comes up often um we
actually have a statute that tells when
effective date should be based upon the
type of Statute so uh yes there is
multiple choices you can be upon passage
which is the governor signing it so
that's still delayed UH 60 days and then
January 1st of the following year and
usually is uh based upon giving the
person whoever potentially be selling
the illegal product to give them time to
get rid of their inventory
representative Gibbs
uh thank you
um
as I'm sure you know
um a legalized cannabis bill has passed
the house
um
how would this bill interact with the
provisions of that bill assuming of
course that that bill passes the Senate
and is signed by the governor which I
know it is it is far from guaranteed but
assuming that bill is enacted and this
bill is enacted
um obviously legalized cannabis contains
THC I think that's the whole point
um so how would how would these two
bills interact
House Bill 639 establishes a rigid
regulatory structure for cannabis
products to be sold including a
limitation on on an age restriction so
21 plus so we have a regulated product
available only to 21 and uh 21 years old
and older
um this would this dovetails with that
and that it it removes these products
that are not regulated so we don't know
what's in them potentially unsafe and
available to minors from the market You
could argue that these these products if
if legalization happen if wreck was
alive and well right now that these
products are directly uh competing with
products that are produced legally
um and at the at the agreed upon tax
rate follow-up question yeah I would say
if you look at the word statute it's 439
A4 it says hemp derived products
so the difference is that 639 is a
cannabis
product when this is just directing the
issue of
hemp uh follow-up question
for the question you may inquire thank
you
um so this bill would prohibit products
not regulated under HB 639 that's
correct okay
um further question uh per well perhaps
um uh the hemp derived is is a
sufficient clarification we might want
to add a little more
um uh wording clarification to make it
clear that the two bills wouldn't
interfere with each other yeah well I
mean normally what we would have said uh
in 639 it was notwithstanding other
statutes but obviously the statute
didn't exist in the books but
um I think that that their way this has
nothing in this chapter
it just basically because this is again
this is the agricultural the products so
it was just saying nothing in this
chapter so it really does not conflict
with 639 at all because thank you there
are different parts of the chapter but
now withstanding that we're still
thinking we're going to have the same
enforcement which would be the liquor
enforcement division House Bill 639 had
a number of amendments as you know
um my belief my memory says that the
definition of cannabis in 639 excludes
hemp
so we can check that to make sure but I
believe 639 has an exclusion that
cannabis that's being regulated by 639
does not include I guess I get the head
okay perfect oh representative Walsh has
another question
thank you Mr chairman
so I understand the cannabis versus this
this still says cannabis in here
so this bill is still talking about
uh use of cannabis
for therapeutic purposes
so should everywhere where it says
cannabis should it be changed to hemp uh
no section one of this bill
um is a different RSA entirely as 126 x
12 with with uh with regard to the
therapeutic cannabis law under the
Department of Health and Human Services
section two is under the hemp bill in
section two RSA 439a has a definition of
hemp that you're not seeing in this uh
okay section one is only for the atcs
which yes that is cannabis section two
is a wholly different section it was a
not somewhat germane amendment when they
the Senate added on there which is
probably unusual for them to find
anything tremendous but uh so but anyway
yeah there are two separate sections two
different Services representative Yemen
thank you Mr chair just one other
question uh
I'm trying to understand where where and
how this problem was created so it was
the 2018 farm bill that the U.S Congress
passed that created this issue is that
correct that is correct again
Matt Simon's going to do some very
thorough cleanup behind me um on on the
history of the hemp bill um but yes the
federal 2018 hemp bill or Farm Bill
legalized industrial hemp and over the
past five years uh technology has been
uh discovered utilized that would allow
CBD derived from illegal Industrial Hemp
federally illegal and state legal
Industrial Hemp to be converted into THC
products okay and for the question
follow-up so uh I'd be curious is there
any effort at the federal level to solve
the problem that they created and what
are they doing about it
yes yes and no uh it's not it's
insufficient um but the feds have done
uh have made certain announcements
regarding certain hemp derived products
um my again my belief is that they have
they have stated that
THC products that do not appear in any
way in a cannabis plant
are still controlled substances and yet
they have not gone so far as to say
Delta nine Delta a and other THC
um uh cannabinoids that are in cannabis
are unlawful uh they're working on it
let alone we know that Federal
government's not the great when it comes
to enforcement of some of the statutes
so on the state level okay thank you
very much
thank you all
okay Matt Simon from primeatc who
good morning Mr chairman honorable
committee
I bet you thought you were done with
cannabis policy for the session sorry to
disappoint you yeah we have no
disillusion that this is just the
beginning
well this bill is much shorter than HP
639 so I'm
confident that we can deal with it in
one day but unfortunately as you've
already gotten to taste the the subject
itself is rather
complicated so
I'll bet some of you are not aware until
this morning that these hemp derived THC
products exist
now you know so I'll back up and explain
just a little bit so for many years one
of the harms associated with cannabis
prohibition is that it created a market
for Dangerous Alternatives people
couldn't go to a store and buy a regular
Botanical Delta 9 cannabis so they would
seek out various Alternatives about a
decade ago we had a study Commission in
New Hampshire dealing with products
called K2 and spice which were called
sometimes synthetic marijuana but really
they were just different types of plant
matter that were sprayed with different
chemicals that were designed to resemble
cannabinoids but weren't really nobody
really knew what they were they produced
a high something like cannabis and
therefore were popular and also very
problematic because they're more harmful
than cannabis and we don't know what
they are so we got our we wrapped our
policy heads around that we prohibited
those products and Flash Forward to 2018
when Congress passed the the hemp
legislation as part of the farm bill at
the time nobody or maybe a very tiny
number of people knew that it was
chemically possible to grow fields of
hemp harvest the CBD cannabidiol and
then use chemicals to convert all of
that CBD into
basically any variant of THC you might
want you can convert it into Delta 9 THC
which is the same molecule that's
available in cannabis or you can convert
it into one of these other varieties of
THC that I'd never heard of until a few
years ago so Delta 8 THC is the one that
became
a really popular thing first I happen to
be in Texas in in February of 2021 when
this broke in the Washington Post
there's this big story about Delta 8
products hemp derived THC and you can
get it anywhere and Texas was Ground
Zero for that so I went straight to the
nearest vape shop I bought a Delta 8
Vape cartridge
look a little something like this and I
I took it to the nearest disc golf
course I inhaled twice I went to The
First Tee and by the time I was on the
First Tee I realized that wow Congress
has legalized THC sales inadvertently
through the hemp law and this is going
to be a policy complication of epic
proportions for states to deal with
um so since then these these products
have proliferated
um they're available in edible form
they're available sometimes you'll see
hemp flowers uh look just like canvas
flower but it's hemp flower and they'll
be sprayed down with these cannabinoids
to to give the effect that resembles
cannabis so
um ten years ago I called spice and K2
the bathtub gin of cannabis prohibition
I I said we need to
make regular cannabis available because
people will always want these
substitutes now fortunately not that
many people are using K2 and spice
that's still available but it's
primarily people are trying to evade a
drug test since those aren't real
cannabinoids they usually won't show up
on a drug test and these products mostly
will show up on a drug test but they're
very popular because they're very
available they are as we've heard
available at gas stations vape shops
mail order uh they're they're really
quite available until really recently
that was just Delta nine I'm sorry Delta
Delta eight and and Delta 10 which are
somewhat less intoxicating than Delta 9
THC
so in recent months I've become very
alarmed to see new THC variants that
I've never heard of and again I've been
I've been consuming Delta 9 THC for over
25 years pretty regularly I it's it's a
substance that's well understood that
humans have thousands of years of
experience with
thco acetate
I'd never heard of that until pretty
recently it's several times more potent
than Delta 9 THC and there are then I
started getting emails about products
called THC H THC JD thcp
the last three I mentioned are all
supposed to be at least 25 times more
potent than Delta 9 THC
so
I'm a little bit alarmed okay I'm
actually pretty alarmed that these
products are widely available and even
if I didn't care about people having bad
experiences with these products I think
they reflect very badly on the regulated
systems that we're trying to create
around actual cannabis
so every time a teenager uses one of
these products that's a statistic the
same as if they used Delta 9 THC if they
get caught at school vaping this and in
the bathroom that gets blamed on legal
regulated cannabis not on a loophole in
the hemp law it this is this was
purchased right down the street by one
of my colleagues that has thcp in it and
if some you know if some kid Vapes that
and has a mental health problem or
something like that resulting that will
be blamed on legal regulated cannabis
not on a loophole in the hemp law
so this bill began as a bill that was I
think hostile to the atcs it was solely
attempting to impose strict labeling
requirements on the atcs these are the
products we sell they're already very
heavily regulated they have to be an
opaque child resistant packaging the all
the cannabinoids have to be displayed on
the label all the terpenes have to be
displayed on the label there's
independent batch specific lab testing
boring Packaging
this was this bill began as a solution
in search of a problem and unlike most
bills that begin that way it actually
found its problem when the Senate
Judiciary Committee learned that there
was a
widespread availability of THC products
that they had not authorized that they
certainly did not intend to authorize in
2019 when they passed the hemp law
they amended this bill to clarify
the hemp law so I I would suggest that
it's completely not only consistent but
essential to the goals of HB 639
not that these products be banned but if
they're going to be sold they need to be
sold within the same regulated system
that other THC products are sold under
and they need to be independently lab
tested in a bad specific way and they
need to be subject to all the same
packaging requirements and the same
gotta show an ID and the same everything
uh to do otherwise is irresponsible
policy and puts the goals of HB 639 very
much at risk in in my opinion so
it's actually been organizations like
normal I passed out normal's guide to
Delta THC and other novel cannabinoids
normal's been advocating for legal
cannabis and and claiming you know the
the lobby that represents canvas
consumers uh in their words and they're
they're leading the charge along with
cannabis journalists at Leafly and other
other outlets it was Leafly that first
shown the light on The Vaping crisis a
few years ago when people were becoming
were developing lung injuries from
unregulated THC Vapes it was Leafly that
that figured out what that actually was
it was an additive called vitamin E
acetate
that was killing people and another
great reason to have regulated supply
chain for cannabis so it's at this point
it's begun to be Leafly in normal joined
by public health organizations I'm
pleased that new Futures is behind me we
often disagree but we agree on this one
again
if people want to try these novel THC
variants I'm all for letting them do
that but they need to know what they're
doing they need to know what these
products are and they should not assume
that
see this on a shelf it looks like a
regulated product it must be legal can't
be bad for me and there's a sense that
well it's made from Cannabis or it's
made from hemp therefore it's safe well
cannabis itself has a well-established
safety profile but squeezing oils out of
it and the big risk is in the chemical
conversion process because when you're
converting CBD to any of these THC
variants you're using chemicals to do it
you're weaving residuals and if you do
not scrub that product very thoroughly
when you're done
it could have anything in it and it's it
should be a cause of concern so
I will I one last thing and then I'll go
to questions uh I just noticed that the
decimal is in the wrong place it should
be 0.3 not 0.03 so good catch
representative and that is something
this committee should fix to be
consistent with federal and state hemp
law
happy to take questions
okay uh representative Herbert is the
first hand I saw
um my question actually is uh a policy
one
what is the policy that we're being
asked to speak to the microphone what is
the policy the policy is is to ban these
products in New Hampshire okay so that
is what we're going to be voting we're
you're voting on Banning hemp derived
products containing THC
I would suggest yes that's correct but
I think it's a little more specific than
that I think it's a clarification that
the hemp law does not authorize the sale
of these products
these products could conceivably be sold
through the regulated system established
by HB 639 that's another section of law
there was a paragraph in there directing
the commission to study hemp derived THC
and and whether it should be sold I
don't know if that's still in the bill
or not but that's something they're
supposed to look at and study but it's
the hemp law that shouldn't be
authorizing these products it wasn't
intended to do so and if they're going
to be sold they should be sold through
the system under 639. for the question
you may inquire
um my question is
um are we here in the committee supposed
to write this law or are we just doing a
policy the law the law is written that's
what the bill is that's the bill the
bill is the law and we're and
yes or no yes yes well I'm hearing that
uh
recommendations this gentleman has made
he's talking about in 639 the bill that
we did pass already
there is a study committee in there
to look into what to do with these uh
hemp products and whether we should
allow them or not and assuming that if
we were to allow them that they would be
licensed and controlled and regulated
just like we did with marijuana in hb639
thank you okay
um I have two questions
um the first is will this bill cover all
I believe it does so the language
includes the line which appear in any
formulation including Delta eight THC
Delta 9 THC or any other THC isomer
variant so I'm not a chemist but my
understanding is that that language
covers if next week There's a THC XYZ
that this would that that would be a THC
isomer variant and it would already be
covered follow-up please father for the
question you inquire my other question
is this this picture that you put for us
it's it's for people that aren't looking
at it it says ghost train Haze Cloud
eight
um mind bending kids are I mean this is
the kind of thing kids are gonna either
put in their pockets or ask a friend to
buy for them is is and I don't know
whether it was legislation that put
cigarettes behind the counter in locked
up but it seems to me these type of
products need to be there as well
yeah I don't believe there's any
regulation at all so we have seen these
products sitting directly on on the just
on the Shelf where somebody a kid could
could reach them and I'll add the back
of that package has has some adjectives
uh hazy euphoric
one of them is Swifty
does anybody know what Swifty is that's
a cartoon reference Rick and Morty uh
get schwifty on Rick and Morty so
um it's not something that we use in our
educational materials at the ATC I can
assure you
okay representative bulliam
yeah thank you Mr chair
um my question is
does anybody know who is making these
products absolutely uh our CEO gets
emails all the time from these companies
trying to sell us kilos of
THC this and THC that we obviously have
to produce everything in-house for for
the therapeutic cannabis program but
they they try to convince us they're 100
Federal illegal and you can buy them for
pennies on the dollar and it's pretty
alarming to us uh but it's largely hemp
companies in places like Texas and
Florida and some other states that have
really developed hemp Industries part of
it's caused by the FDA abdicating its
responsibility to regulate CBD products
they've grown all this CBD there there's
demand for CBD products but there's also
demand for this stuff and if you can
make more converting it they're they're
doing what makes sense to them
economically until somebody tells them
it depends on who you ask
we're going to make it illegal
representative
thank you Mr chairman uh
question for you based on the uh
testimony we've just heard with respect
to 0.03 so uh and then a question for Mr
Simon 0.03
this is what was passed by the Senate so
we're going to have to clean this up
this bill will need some Amendment yes
this will go to a subcommittee this
afternoon right so assuming that we
change this to 0.3 which we will then we
pass this and it's got to go back to the
Senate they will have to concur this is
not just the typographical error they
actually passed this at 0.03 yeah that
okay okay so the question for you sir is
um
um can you tell me about 0.03 why not
0.02 or 0.00 or 0.04 what's the science
on this and why was Zero as we now know
Wise was 0.3 selected
thank you for the question I I don't
know but that was the policy decision
made by Congress when it passed the
federal hemp legislation and that was
the policy decision made by New
Hampshire legislature when it passed New
Hampshire's hemp legislation so it is
0.3 and that's generally accepted to be
the the standard for for hemp
so Paul so presumably there's some
science
to the effect that less than 0.3
is not a problem but point three is is
some kind of a threshold where anything
at point three or above is deemed to be
dangerous
this is just like that we with beer
right now with beer
that you know that it was point it's 0.5
is considered and basically the the
issue was always is that some products
just have it naturally like beer you
know some things you can't
you can't truly get it all the alcohol
out it has something so they set it to
Minimus it's a federal number so we're
not Reinventing any wheel here we're
taking a number that the feds had
already had already analyzed it and
decided that the THC as long as it has
we still don't know the answer to the
question but we're adopting the federal
0.3 correct we don't but we you can't
answer my question nobody knows thanks
and this may thank you and this may be a
clarification that I'm asking for
So based on everything that I've heard
it sounds like even though you define
something as hemp and it's 0.3 THC uh
Delta 9 I think is what they defining it
as that variety not any other variety
that variety correct you can chemically
alter
0.3 THC hemp
THD Delta 9 temp into a whole bunch of
other things that can in fact end up
being much worse
than the delta 9.
that's correct what's in typically in
cannabis yeah and to clarify it's not
the the small amount of th Delta 9 THC
that's being converted in most cases
it's the very large amount of CBD hemp
plants produce large amounts of
non-psychoactive CBD and that's what's
being chemically converted there are two
Federal there are two arguments that
these companies make when they say these
products are federally legal one is that
anything made from hemp is a legal hemp
product a natural hemp product as long
as it does not contain more than 0.3
percent THC so one of the loopholes is
actually to make edibles
that are very bulky and they're bulky
enough to comply with that so it's point
three percent but it's like imagine a
loaf of bread that's 0.3 percent THC
that would have enough THC to get some
somebody plenty intoxicated so that's
one of the legal theories we're seeing
bulky Edibles that actually do contain
Delta 9 sold and they're claiming it's
Fairly Legal the other is that
it hinges on whether these products are
synthetic or natural
so there's a federal analogs act
that says synthetic drugs are illegal
and in my opinion these are all
synthetics because they're being
synthesized you're taking CBD you're
adding chemicals you're making a new
compound that barely exists in nature
and to me that's very plainly a
synthetic
but the DEA somehow has taken the
position that if it occurs in nature in
any amount which Delta 8 does in Trace
Amounts then well you know it's it's
it's it's a natural product because it's
made from hemp and if you're trying to
sow chaos like do what the DEA has done
they did say that thco acetate is a
synthetic because it doesn't appear in
nature so that one THC isomer variant
DEA is helpfully clear a lot clarified
as federally illegal there are other
federal agencies that don't share that
view and that do consider these products
to be federally illegal based on the
federal analogs act
there are not really a lot of court
cases uh on this that would help us out
so states have been left to make policy
for themselves and many have seen fit to
do what you're looking at doing which is
clarifying hemp legislation
and and I would state for everyone if
the people who are manufacturing this
product
if
they really didn't want us to ban it
they would be here today
okay so the fact that we have no
opposition to this bill take a letter is
that this is the right answer at this
point to ban it and if they're at some
point in time that they think that they
can come up with a legitimate product
that's safe and that we have a study
committee that will be able to listen to
that conversation but today we need to
get this statute passed
thank you very
representative Walsh
thank you Mr I'm just trying to move
things along we have other people want
to speak and I just it's quick but it's
going to be something new and different
right
somewhat
if you prohibit and you ban doesn't that
mean
nothing zero zilch
so to touch upon representative Terry's
Point why does this have any percentage
you can't you can't answer the question
I mean I'm not an expert on hemp policy
the idea was
policymakers wanted to draw a line
somewhere and they wanted to draw the
line somewhere where plainly you could
not grow the flower and smoke it and get
high and that is true of 0.3 percent THC
flour I think they were not thinking
about all the things that could then be
manufactured and processed from that
flower
just like right now with beer the
non-alcohol beer
okay it has to be less than 0.5
and my understanding is and when I can
pursue that argument this question was
that sometimes you just can't get it all
out so believe it or not you might be
eating a fruit
that has alcohol in it less than 0.5
alcohol and you don't know that and they
haven't tested where they didn't label
it because we never require them to
label it but that some fruit just
naturally fermented and created an
alcohol that's very low level alcohol
you can't get drunk from it just like
you can't get stoned from this stuff
representative Hammond
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Simon
for your testimony um
I don't usually Preamble my questions
but I'm going to do a little bit here
it's my understanding that these
products exist mainly do be due to
Prohibition right they're they're
loopholes around existing laws
and now we're talking about another
prohibition to solve
the results of the prior prohibition
and I guess we're not asking a question
what are the unintended consequences of
prohibiting these
products that exist because of
prohibition could they go to the black
market
could they you know if our taxes on
regulated cannabis go too high
could these come in in a Black Market
approach to undercut those taxes what
are the unintended consequences if you
could speculate thank you
thank you for the question
um
you know the consequences I'm most
concerned about which
there are a lot of people who want to
consume THC in New Hampshire and in the
U.S we know that and they have options
they're options are to go to a regulated
retail store in Massachusetts which I
think is a good option if you're going
to consume cannabis all of their
products are independently lab tested
they're labeled appropriately
and sold in a responsible fashion New
Hampshire's therapeutic cannabis program
another example well-regulated products
that's where I would want people to go
I would not want people to buy
unregulated products if I cared about
their health because they might be just
fine or they might be very harmful
the independent testing that has been
done of these products has found that
many of them are just not what they say
they are they either contain way more of
the Delta eight or whatever THC it is or
weigh less some of them contain Delta 9
THC without saying they do and a lot of
them contain pesticides impurities heavy
metals that we should all be alarmed by
especially in the context of a vape
cartridge something you're inhaling
directly into your lungs so
and I can think of no case or I would
recommend that a friend of mine go buy
one of these products when they could be
buying actual cannabis or actual
regulated cannabis products so
okay
we do have more people to testify maybe
you can ask that next person your
question
okay so thank you very much uh Tim Egan
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee thank you for taking the time
to hear my testimony I'll try to be
brief and
I may not be able to answer all your
questions Matt I look as an expert so um
one second sorry my computer's a little
slow here
good afternoon my name is Timothy Egan
I'm a former representative from Sugar
Hill
um and currently a member of the New
Hampshire Canada trade Council as well
today I am here as the chair of New
Hampshire cannabis Association the
state's leading trade group for the
Cannabis industry and proponents of safe
use of regulated cannabis and I
bring that to bear in this bill
Senate Bill 180 that we are proponents
of regulated cannabis use and this is
why this bill is an issue and that we
are here to support it
um we are police support Senate Bill 180
relative to product labeling and
information guide requirements for
cannabis products and the prohibition of
sale of hemp products containing certain
levels of THC while the farm bill of
2018 allowed hemp to be defined in the
legislation as a cannabis plant yes the
same ones that produce marijuana there
is one key difference that hemp cannot
contain more than 0.3 percent of THC
and the key is that that compound in the
plant is most commonly associated with
people getting some type of high and
that more than 0.3 percent is where that
psychoactive opportunity begins in the
brain
in short
what was passed in the farm bill is that
hemp should not be able to get you high
but the bill allowed Innovative new
cannabis products to be created that can
give you that similar feeling like a
Delta a or a Delta 9. and like in all
Industries innovation without regulation
can have a negative impact
to that end New Hampshire can wants to
participate in creating an adult use
cannabis Market that New Hampshire can
be proud of
allowing hemp derived Tac products to be
sold without mandatory ID checks
consumer education or independent lab
testing is irresponsible public policy
and undermines the goals expressed by
this committee when passing House Bill
639 it's important that regulation in
any type of consumer-oriented ingested
product is followed intelligently
support South Senate Bill 180 so that we
can ensure that all THC products are
sold within a reasonably regulated
system this bill was developed with
guidance from a coalition of
stakeholders the medicinal industry
Health Care Professionals Educators
Agriculture and proponents of the adult
use industry it's important that the
proponents one of the key proponents of
the adult use industry New Hampshire can
is here to support this bill
New Hampshire touts itself is
pro-business and supports individual
liberties and local control once low
taxes wants to draw young people to our
state but we can do all this and we can
protect our consumers we can protect our
young people it's important that
previous testimony noted that there is
no
age
delineation on being able to acquire
this product
in fact I did a test of similar to what
Matt did when this came out I was
actually in Florida I walked into a
convenience store I purchased it
they didn't ask me anything I remembered
it vividly because I had been a
proponent of uh you know legalization
for the last 15 years
and I was surprised by
that was just hanging up there with the
key chains and the gum and the mints
right at the counter where you can make
your impulse Buy
so it's important that we figure out how
to regulate it and if
a house bill 639 does pass through the
Senate and does become law in the state
there are Provisions in that bill to
help regulate this industry it's our
assessment
at New Hampshire can that Republic that
responsible public policy can be
accomplished with Senate bill 180. so I
thank you for taking the time and I'll
do my best to answer any questions
yeah perfect thank you representative
Gibbs did you have a question
thank you Mr chairman uh yes this is the
question that I was going to ask the
previous
um uh testifier
um uh is it your expectation that
House Bill third house bill 639
um and the um uh process that will be
established assuming that that is
enacted
um would greatly reduce the
attractiveness of any products uh such
as are described in this bill if they
were to be sold on the black market
quickly I'll say yes but I would like to
explain that I think what's important in
House Bill 639 that was uh as well in
some of the Amendments was that we
included an educational aspect of if
legalization was then passed that the
consumers of New Hampshire would be
educated about what is in adult use THC
products and I think that's an important
part that would come out in this was be
able to explain that there are other
derivative products that could be
harmful to you
and explain the the difference between
adult use flour or edibles and a Delta 9
or a Delta a and so yes you're
that bill would help
better educate consumers and warn them
about
products that are produced without
regulation without control and it could
potentially be manipulated by the black
market which we have seen in Vape
cartridges tied to cigarette vaping
thank you
spear
excuse me thank you have you noticed if
this
is tracking any of the poisoning is in
problems that are happening with these
Oddball unregulated
um
hemp products I have not been following
that actually you're just going to give
me more homework to do because actually
that'd be wise to do
um but like similar testimony I think
we're understanding that
until
we begin to look into the
reasonings why there are
poisonings or ER visits or all of the
commentary that opponents to adult use
cannabis have articulated making sure
that we understand where those numbers
come from and what it's attributed to
blending their cannabis with something
else are they using products like Delta
8 and Delta 9. I think that would be an
important piece of research and again
that's also in House Bill 639 is
studying the impact of it so that we
understand what our regulation does I
think if I may commend this committee
and commend ways and means you all took
a intelligent amount of time in a
bipartisan conversation to create good
pieces of legislation that has gone over
to the Senate we're hoping that the
Senate sees that but I think the
research part the study of impact part
the protections and support for law
enforcement and and utilization of
operating vehicle under use
of a substance those are all things that
are in that bill that I think will help
solve some of these problems that
outlier Industries like Delta and Delta
9 are giving the bad name for the adult
representative Yemen
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
our questions
so I think I heard you earlier in your
testimony you mentioned that you
purchased a vape pen in the State of
Florida is that correct yes sir so this
is a nationwide issue and I'm curious
what other states we can't be the first
ones to notice this right what other
states are
what approach are other states taking
you know on the spectrum of legalization
to a complete prohibition and there's a
spectrum there what other other states
are doing if I would thank you for the
question I wish I could tell you that I
had time to focus on the issue with
Delta 8 and Delta 9 in other states
obviously I've been focused on the you
know the issue with adult use here in
New Hampshire as well as in the state of
Vermont where I'm an educator in the
Castleton cannabis studies program but
you just gave me an assignment for my
students next semester which is to look
at the impact of Delta and Delta 9
because I have not been able to I've
obviously been focused on
sort of what I would refer to as job one
which was making a smart intelligent
um sorry for the repetitive intelligent
you know use adult use here
um
I will get back to you on that though
representative I'm sure our next
speaker will have an answer for that
question thank you very much thank you
very much everyone okay Kate you you get
the last word
good morning
good morning members of the committee my
name is Kate Frye from new Futures at
Public Health policy organization that
works on
um many different Health policy issues
including Alcohol and Other Drugs uh
issues so that's why I'm here today
um so I'll be very brief because you've
heard a lot on this issue but we are
here in support of this bill it is uh an
issue that you are correct New Hampshire
is not the only state that is dealing
with this
um other states are dealing with this I
have provided you a handout that does
give you background information already
very um candidly provided to you by
other speakers about the issue but also
what other states have done regarding um
trying to get their hands around this
issue this loophole I do agree with
representative hunt that this is very
similar to some other issues that we've
looked at in the past to me this reminds
me a lot of the issue we had
this reminds me of what you always say
when I was in the room when this
happened is that the powdered alcohol
issue that we had 10 years ago or so
where again this issue was coming up uh
somewhat dangerous
um product was being created and there
was no Authority
um within the state to regulate it and
so it did remind me of the fact that the
New Hampshire Liquor Commission was
granted authority to then
if it was to come into the state to take
care of it so I did want you to know
ahead of time that I did have
conversations with the Liquor Commission
um they do see this product they are
concerned about this product they were
supposed to be here today they have said
in the past that
um by prohibiting it that would be easy
for them at this point to just say you
know you can't sell these in the state
right now
um to move into more of a regular story
structure would obviously be uh more
financially uh they need more resources
for that
um and that's something that they you
know you can have that discussion with
them
um but it would be because they already
the way I understand that have the
licensure authority over most of these
stores that are selling these except for
maybe CBD stores that they would have
the authority to say these products
cannot be sold here
as far as you know
down the line what this could look at
some states have chosen to have them in
the regulatory structure and I think
that would be fine if we chose to go in
that direction I think the major concern
as you heard is really just about the
safety of these so we would just expect
to have the same standard of making sure
that they are lab tested these products
are safe but I think we are a little
down the line from that because we don't
have a regulatory structure for cannabis
or hemp at this point so I think this is
pretty straightforward by prohibiting it
at this time and again I would defer you
to The Liquor Commission but I think our
conversations were that they identify
this as a problem and felt that this was
a good solution for now
okay
questions representative purselli do you
happen to know if this product is being
manufactured in New Hampshire or is it
all brought in from other states I think
defer to others but my understanding for
the most part it's brought in from other
states
representative Ammon
sure
there's still an open question of what
other states are doing to address this
issue I think you said and the last page
of this document it gives you kind of a
summary of different approaches other
states have taken
around it so you know under uh on page
five so prohibit
um the manufacturing salaries that's
kind of I think what this bill is doing
North Dakota is doing that
um regulating it it's showing you what
states have some states or I don't think
it points out specifically which states
but it kind of shows you different
structures and I can probably get you a
more detailed map somewhere too this is
somewhat new so it's evolving as we go
along but it does show you different
regulatory structures or different poly
structures states have taken
for the question
in uh you're providing that information
is there a way that you can give us
specific legislation bills in other
states I think yeah I can look into it
all right great I don't know if I can do
it by this afternoon when you're exactly
but it's just a subcommittee so yeah I
can see what I can find see what you can
find first that'd be great
okay
we're all set thank you very much we'll
close the public hearing uh Senate Bill
180 I would say that uh online there was
two support and four opposed to this
bill
and uh one one uh the blue sheets uh
Elizabeth sergeant from the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police are in support of the bill
with that we'll move right on to our
next bill Senate Bill 201 and I see
senator
Chancellor
good morning good morning I apologize
for this delay but I'm sure you found
that that hearing very entertaining
yes and it's interesting because I serve
on Commerce and Judiciary in the Senate
so I was thinking did I hear this bill
which in which committee did I hear this
bill
um so good morning members of the
committee my name is Shannon shandley
and I represent uh Senate District 11 in
the state senate
um it is my privilege to be here before
you for a second time this session
um this time on a wholly different topic
I'm here to introduce Senate Bill 201 an
act relative to the sale of event
tickets
um I will note that this bill was
changed
amended significantly in the Senate and
I I think that the current bill before
you is
um is a very good bill and one which I
will ask for you to look favorably upon
quite simply this bill provides some
very limited but much needed protection
for our New Hampshire small businesses
and our consumers
there are a couple of people here who
can give you first-hand accounts of
their experiences
dealing with uh tickets that are sold
online for events at their venues which
are not authorized by their venues it
leads to a tremendous confusion
loss of income often the consumers do
not even have the ticket they thought
that they were purchasing
now let me give you just a little bit of
background
um so shortly after the start of the
pandemic the governor uh
established the governor's task force on
reopening and I uh to which Governor
sununu appointed me and it was our job
to look at all various sectors of the
economy and kind of figure out under
which conditions that each could safely
reopen to the public that task for that
task force did its job and and worked
very closely from the start of the
pandemic through probably
May or June of 2020 but one of the
things that came about I'd worked very
closely with folks in the Arts Community
both the per Performing and the visual
arts and with individuals and
organizations and uh one of the
Silver Linings and I think it's hard to
say the pandemic had a silver lining but
one of the good things that came out of
the task force and the work that was
being done among the Arts Community is
the way folks join together to problem
solve and collaborate and Advocate and I
would say that this bill sb201 is a
product of that continued problem
solving and collaboration
uh the Performing Arts were incredibly
hard hit by the pandemic and they have
recovered uh somewhat more slowly than
other sectors and the community
continues to meet to address the
problems one significant issue that has
emerged is um the unau authorized
reselling of event tickets at Cost
significantly above the face value by
online outfits that are not affiliated
with the venue but often give the
appearance of being associated with that
venue uh the digital component of this
ticket reselling really has exacerbated
and intensified the offense and its
consequences
it's often deceptive includes fraud and
fakery and there are some stories that I
know you will hear that will Boggle your
mind perhaps
this isn't you know I'm not talking
about
um
the big National problem that many of us
have heard about what I'm really talking
about is
um the problem as as it exists for the
producing and presenting venues and for
the patrons in the state of New
Hampshire our constituents are
purchasing tickets from what they
believe to be a venue box office for
sums well above the actual ticket price
and what I mean by that is they could go
to the venue or to The Venue website and
purchase a ticket often for one-third of
the price that is showing up on the
um
quite often the tickets don't exist at
all or the vendors selling them the
ticket doesn't yet own the ticket so
they purchase a ticket and then the
vendor from which they purchased the
ticket then goes to the box office
purchase the tickets on
sells it gets it to the patron
one of the problems with this is
sometimes that ticket's already been
sold it's not available so uh they are
they're not necessarily getting the
um
what this bill does in its amended
version is it requires those venues
which are selling the tickets uh to
patrons
to do a few very simple things it
requires them to prominently display uh
on the
in bold type
certain conditions first that the seller
may not actually own the ticket that the
seller is a different entity from the
venue
that the ticket may be part of a of a
block or a Zone and isn't necessarily
the one the person thinks he or she is
purchasing and um and then finally it
requires the purchaser to acknowledge
that the purchaser is aware of those
circumstances
it is
really important to our small businesses
in the state and certainly important to
our consumers that we pass this piece of
legislation I'm happy to take any
questions and I do want to assure you
that the folks who will speak after me
can tell you the specifics about what
they have encountered in their
businesses thank you Mr chair
thank you I've been caught in this kind
of thing myself and it's it's it's
horrible
but the problem
how would you legislate an out-of-state
organization who's doing these kind of
shenanigans
to pay any attention to it I mean
Nothing Stops anybody from putting
anything they want online
um well I I guess I would
disagree a little bit that not there are
things just to discourage people and I
think having
um the Attorney General's office the
consumer protection division uh act on
this if this is a violation of Law and
an organization is
engaging in it that can be filed with
the Attorney General's office and the
consumer protection division can act on
it I will say you know there are
penalties in place that they can uh
put
what's the word I'm looking for that
they can uh put upon the
um those who violate it
and I'm not saying it's going to resolve
all of our problems but I'm saying it's
the right thing to do to protect the
consumer and to protect the businesses
in the state it is hard I I certainly do
not disagree at all that enforcement of
this kind of uh consumer of this kind of
violation can be difficult but it
doesn't mean that we don't try
representative Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman
um I have one question
um regarding uh the options given for
what must be disclosed and essentially
the the seller
um has three options of what to disclose
one is that they don't actually own the
ticket the other is that
um uh it's a different entity than the
venue where the event or performance is
to be held and the third is that it's
it's a block
um uh zone or or
some other category uh rather than an
individual ticket
um my question is
um if the seller say does not actually
own the ticket and is a different entity
than the venue where the uh event is to
be held
um don't we want both of those things
disclosed not just one or the other is
if I were buying a ticket I would want
to know always whether or not the seller
actually owns the ticket and whether or
not the seller is actually
um the box office uh where I thought I
was going to buy the ticket from
thank you very much for that question my
understanding and my intent is that all
of those things would have to be
disclosed if
all of them were true whichever one is
true all must be disclosed and if um if
for some reason we think the wording
isn't saying that we you know I'm open
to to Really buying that problem then
follow up then uh we do need to uh
revise a language to say and we will we
will be putting this bill the
subcommittee and working it thank you
representative Burroughs
thank you for taking my question
um I may have not read read the amended
I'm not sure which version I read but I
guess I wanted to clarify that this
would not not impact an individual who
had a ticket they couldn't use selling
to a friend not a you know to another
person perfect thank you
even though it doesn't say that that
it's supposed to be online
right the Bill's supposed to be an
online purchase yes these are yeah if it
doesn't even though it doesn't say it it
self okay
representative Sullivan
thank you uh you mentioned loss of
income I'm curious what loss of income
so and this is a this is a uh
uh can be a very big question a
difficult question for the venues one
way that it would result in loss of
income is dependent on how the venue
handles it so for example
um a person may purchase two tickets to
go see an event at one of our local
theaters the person purchases the
tickets from one of these online
resources and it turns out when the
people get to the venue the tickets are
not good that they were somehow they
either were not purchased the seat has
been sold twice it is a fake
um then the venue then has to deal with
some very disturbed and upset patrons
it's the people at the box office who
then have to try to explain the
situation and the folks who sent who
paid the money are out they have lost
that money so those so one way or
another someone has lost money the
people who paid the paid for the tickets
that don't exist would have lost their
money the box office and I believe that
in sometimes the box offices will find
those patrons a seat but they're not
being paid a second time for the seat so
the box office is actually out because
they didn't they're they're providing
um
a ticket to people who didn't actually
pay them for the ticket and the other
issue which is a little bit more
complicated and isn't addressed
necessarily by this bill but it is what
are you paying for and the idea is that
you're paying for your ticket is in some
ways a license it's a license to sit in
a particular seat for a particular
performance
um and you know it's a different
question I think who who can
um
who has established that contract in
between which parties does that contract
exist but that is a slightly different
issue from the one that this bill
addresses
further question okay so what you just
described at least a situation where
somebody goes in and they don't actually
have the tickets or they're fake I mean
that to me already sounds illegal so I'm
not sure how this law would fix that or
is there some Gap in our law that allows
this illegal what sounds like should be
an illegal practice to exist
um I think it's selling a fraudulent
tickets should be legal right no yes it
should be and I think that this makes it
very clear so one of the things we have
so for example let's say
um a person comes in and says well I
paid
150 dollars for this ticket but I see
right here that you're selling tickets
for fifty dollars that often it's it's
creating a problem with the venue and I
think one of the things you'll hear well
you know buyers should be aware of these
things these many of these websites are
set up so well and you are so easily
directed to them that buyers buyers
can't be aware of things that aren't
disclosed to them so what I'm this bill
is attempting to do is
attempting to help the buyer be aware
by putting in the
um conditions under which the ticket is
being sold
thank you
representative Yemen thank you Mr chair
thank you senator for taking our
questions I guess I have two unrelated
questions if I may uh the first one is
what is the penalty if someone is caught
doing this what so uh it would be
the uh
there's uh write a prayer of action you
oh you can pursue it yourself you're the
right of private action
another question uh second unrelated
question uh I'll paint a scenario uh
there's a concept I really want to see
the tickets are very expensive maybe
it's Barry Manilow or Bert Bacharach or
or Neil Diamond
but some something I really want to say
I've been Dynasty but then I have a
family emergency
and I I spent all this money on these
tickets and the money means a lot to me
and I want to sell the tickets on eBay
so I can recoup my money does this would
this apply to me I don't think it does
we've written it was originally the bit
way the bill was written it would have
applied to you I think in this case if
you're selling something on eBay eBay
that's a completely different
okay we have a lot of other people
but I think okay representative here
it's a short question
we have you listed some things in the
bill that that need to be on those
websites that are selling the tickets
and that that all seems fine
shouldn't we have information on the
venue itself putting up information
because let's say I'm gonna go buy I'm
going to go to a concert the first thing
I'm going to do is go to the venue
and there should be some kind of big
thing here don't buy the tickets unless
you see these things otherwise I
wouldn't even know
that there is an issue I do think that
is a very good question and I know that
two of the other folks who are here
um are affiliated with venues and can
really address that better than I can I
do know also and I suggest I really ask
all of you to um
go online
choose one of the concerts that or uh
performances that are taking place in
the state go online and uh
I would even suggest you know go online
and just see what the process is see how
quickly you can be redirected to a site
that isn't the
um authorized venue and then see what
kind of information is available to you
there you it's it's fascinating when you
do this
um we have so many wonderful uh small
venues in our state every one of you
probably has
um or if not in your District nearby
your District
reach out to those folks the people who
are in your area or near your area and
ask them if they've encountered this
problem and what they are trying to do
representative Gibbs uh thank you Mr
chairman
um
isn't the problem and this is something
that I've run into not actually with
concert venues myself but rather with
hotels that you can go online and search
for something and be directed rather
than to what you thought you were
going to purchase something from instead
to a broker as I said this has happened
to me with hotels where I went online to
search for a hotel to reserve a room and
discovered later on that the site where
I had reserved the room and put down a
deposit was actually a broker not the
hotel and I only found this out when
um uh when I discovered that customer
service okay I think I think I think we
get the question so we got the question
we know the question yes I think she
gets the question isn't that the problem
that when you search for the venue you
may in fact get something else and if
that other site doesn't tell you
downside of the internet that is correct
yes and I think that that is this will
help consumers understand what they're
what they're doing so putting the
warning on the menu website wouldn't
solve the problem okay thank you
would you believe
yes
yeah okay thank you
thank you
all right thank you very much you're
welcome thank you for your consideration
so we do have several vendors here but
what I think the next person I want to
bring up Mary Stewart from the Attorney
General's office
who doesn't take a position but would
like to give us some insight on
enforcement of this statute
if we were to pass it thank you
um Tucson okay yeah yeah so I'm Mary
Stewart from the consumer protection
Division and yes so the the way this
bill is structured which is good it's in
the as a violation if you
um do not do these proper disclosures it
would be a violation that a consumer
protection statute so to answer one of
the questions that came up
um the Attorney General can clearly
enforce uh New Hampshire law against
entities that are out of state that are
doing business in New Hampshire so it
would cover that and the damages that
are available under the consumer
protection statute would also be damages
that a person could pursue which are
actual damages but if we do it it would
be restitution and possible civil
penalties as well so so there are so
that whole piece is is good we do have a
just one concern really about in
enforcement and that is
and this was kind of alluded to to some
of the questions the term seller is not
clearly defined in the statute so in the
situation of if a consumer were to file
a complaint they bought a ticket online
let's say the online platform was more
of a broker instead of the actual
individual that was selling the ticket
it raises a question of who is
responsible to provide these disclosures
is it the broker like StubHub or some of
those others entities or is it the
actual individual
and that just goes to who are we
pursuing who are we seeking to enforce
the statute against
and that's our primary comment the other
thing and this could just be are
just we weren't sure where when you say
a ticket is being resold in a block zone
or other specific grouping of ticket
that wasn't really clear to us what that
meant
um or my third comment which we didn't
catch but was an excellent comment that
was made is if all of these I totally
agree that the way this is written only
even if all three of these disclosures
were
apply to the ticket the way the statute
is written only one would have to be
disclosed technically so that certainly
should be addressed as well
and that's all I have any questions uh
Evan we do representative Terry so to be
perfectly clear
in response to this your concern
is that this might actually
apply to representative Ammon who is
attempting to resell his ticket on eBay
well
we actually talked about that and we
don't think it would because because
this is under the consumer protection
act which regulates Trader Commerce and
individual that's not kind of in the
business of selling tickets wouldn't
necessarily fall under the larger scope
of the ACT
is that further questions is that clear
from your reading of the statute or
could it be clearer or is this just your
interpretation
So based on defining the seller I think
that's why defining who the seller is is
really important yeah seller needs work
so it needs work okay representative
thank you Mr chair uh I'm just looking
at uh line 11 on page two where it talks
about acknowledgment
and it uses some uh like in Internet
terms with check boxes and radio buttons
and so forth so if I'm
if I'm on the street and I'm wearing a
trench coat
and I open it up to you and I say would
you like to buy some tickets
uh what what would the acknowledgment
well
what was the acknowledgment I guess you
it has to have some indication of
acknowledgment so
this is contemplating
that this the purchaser I mean you'd
have to show that the purchaser
acknowledges your
the disclosures that you are making I
guess I mean arguably I would say would
need to be in writing you know some sort
of writing I don't think that this bill
is is really targeted to kind of
person-to-person sales right so let's
get back to the sponsor said yeah it was
it was a tent that this was an internet
transaction yeah so again there's this
if we're going to pass this there's a
lot more meat that needs to be added
that needs to be added I would say yes
yep okay thank you very much thank you
all right now we have
three venues we'll start off with a
former state legislator Peter Ramsey
and uh
it's good to be back I was here for
about uh 30 years
starting at 21 and uh loved my time here
and uh am very proud and thank you all
for serving it's hard to be a a elected
representative nowadays it's not easy I
don't think it ever was Mr chairman but
thank you all for serving so
um I run the Palace Theater in
Manchester New Hampshire I'm very proud
to do that I want to thank senator
chandley for her great work on this uh
she's become a good friend over the last
four years she made a tremendous
difference during covid the Palace
Theater for example was close to 17
months it cost us seven million dollars
and Senator chandley helped us raise
some money it was wonderful
so to go to this bill this is a bit
complicated and I brought my phone not
to be rude Mr chairman but but if you
type in Palace Theater
um you you you automatically will see
four or five
ticket sellers I don't call them
resellers they are they have copied our
website
and they are selling our tickets to
every show we do uh we will do this year
about 400 different events uh we opened
rent
um on Friday night it's our production
we have 20 professional actors from
around America here for a month and on
Friday night we had 600 people at the
theater in Manchester from all over New
England
um and a woman came up to the box office
five minutes before the show and said my
ticket won't work at the door we have a
um a ticket scanner at the door
and she said my ticket doesn't work well
if you looked at the ticket it wasn't
our ticket it was a fake ticket sold by
Vivid tickets which is a big operation
and she our tickets uh if you call the
box office or go under our website are
no more than forty five dollars that's
what we charge on purpose we're a
non-profit venue we want people in New
Hampshire and Manchester to come to the
Palace to be to improve their their
everyday life
we work hard at keeping our tickets
cheaper this poor woman had paid 200 a
ticket she had two tickets
she wanted number one she wanted a
ticket that worked number two she wanted
her money back well the Palace Theater
can't give money back I never got the
money it was sold to this Vivid website
and on the top of the Vivid website
in very small letters you can't really
see you can't see it on your cell phone
it says ticket reseller was it isn't
reselling
they are copying our our business in
selling it online and I think my friend
Sal from the capital Center will repeat
the same thing I'm telling you it's it's
only been going on for about two years
it it never happened in the old days as
I said I've been at the palace for 25
years it never used to happen
um there there always were people who
had bought four tickets two other
friends couldn't come they would stand
outside and try to sell it I never
complained about it I was happy they
were there
and oftentimes and giving tickets away
to friends or something and that's fine
I don't think this bill is is addressing
that at all uh this bill is not perfect
but it's a good start and and I think
that that
I'm not here on behalf of the palace I'm
here on behalf of our consumers we will
sell about 150
000 tickets this year
almost every night of the week
and our consumers every night are being
affected by this because think about it
somebody tells you oh go see rents at
the palace it's a great show
you pick up your cell phone oh gee I
hope I can get tickets and you don't
think about it
I've done it before myself I was in uh
obviously Manchester England and wanted
to go see a sold out soccer game I ended
up paying way too much and and I was
offended and I had trouble getting into
place but uh so it happens all the time
it's big big business for these for
these fake websites so I'm happy to
answer any questions uh it's very
complicated
um and I'm so proud to have the Attorney
General's office here because I think
they could make a big difference
so thank you very much Mr chairman it's
good to see you again and uh I'm happy
to questions representative thackson
hi I've never been to your theater and I
apologize for that but well if you want
to come I'll get you two free tickets
you can come next Friday
if they're over 25 you have to claim
them I'm sorry Mr chairman you're right
I'm sorry they're 45 that's a problem
I'm sorry
but no I couldn't claim them uh but my
real point is so while you were talking
I looked at this I found this Vivid
Seats thing yep and you'll be happy to
know when I searched the first thing
that came up was your theater site
I had to actually go all the way down
the page to find Vivid Seats oh good and
so they claim
that they have a hundred percent and I'm
just I want perspective on this that's
sure I'm not advertising for them uh
they have a 100 million seats sold 100
buyer guarantee there's no way in here I
wouldn't know that but the thing that I
really want to make sure I understood
the words you said correctly
in their website they say the average C
at your theater is 95 88.
is that correct I thought you said forty
five dollars well this is where it gets
really complicated the average price is
95 if I buy it from them on on on Vivid
but that's not reselling because they
don't have my ticket
well that's what I'm trying to
understand because if I think it's fraud
Mr chairman
I mean well the question is is that
they'll say they'll go get the ticket
for you but you're going to pay twice as
much absolutely for us to do the the
legwork for you but but on on so
um it's very complicated but
but and I'd love to hear what the
Attorney General's office has to say
about this but she's left the room oh
okay but
they are not selling my ticket or our
ticket at The Palace Theater we can show
our tickets sure and what they're doing
is copying our website
are are
um uh show the advertising for the show
which in itself is illegal I have to pay
rights to advertise for rent
they're not doing that they're selling
to the poor consumer
a 95 dollar ticket that I could have
gone on the first website that came up
and bought from you for 45 bucks correct
which I assume you would email to me or
whatever correct or or you could pick it
up at the box office
yeah I'm old school I'd probably pick it
up at the box right right and and 70
it's funny when I first started in the
theater business
99 of tickets were bought in person yeah
now 70 percent are bought online so this
is a real problem for the venues in New
Hampshire
but probably venues every place but
correct our concerns representative
spear
I mean they're obviously doing some
illegal stuff I agree I have tried we've
spent a lot of time on this and uh I've
called the FBI
um uh and a lot of different law
enforcement people and it's really hard
to take action on a two hundred dollar
well Friday night would have been a 400
fraud in
and I have a follow-on question and the
the hooker is that they haven't
defrauded us they've defrauded the poor
consumer and now unfortunately the
credit card companies are not making the
patron hole so this woman started to cry
it it was awful but but for the question
main choir
you've said that they've they don't have
the right to advertise rent you know the
in the case that this thing because you
own the rights that's a violation
against you
if the FBI can't help and anybody else
can't help
how are we going to happen so well let's
say basically why have you had asked
rent whether they care enough to have
them pursue the case because I'm sure
they got lawyers and I have not but it's
a good idea Mr chairman yeah it's a good
idea so because they're the ones who are
harmed you know because you have to show
harm right exactly you're not doing harm
it has to be the consumer to bring the
case so okay
any other and representative Yemen thank
you Mr chair I just want to understand
how this bill applies to the scenario
that you painted so the website has a
very tiny font right then the bill says
it's got to be 14 point font so that's
that would apply and then one of the
three conditions has to be displayed
and then there's some kind of
acknowledgment check box on the on the
checkout but other than that that
website that you they can charge
whatever they want
um they can't defraud a customer
obviously they have to provide a ticket
for some price but
um this bill would modify that
reseller's website to to this degree and
then they would still be able to operate
provided they they give the ticket is
that correct
well it's complicated and as I said and
I'm serious about this I don't think
this is a perfect bill I I think it's a
great first start and I'm proud of what
the Senate did I think it's going to
help the consumer in that if someone
defraud it for four or five hundred
dollars I think that person then could
call the New Hampshire Attorney
General's office and let them go to and
go to work
um if if Vivid
um Ticket Company wherever they are
if they start getting letters and
notices from the Attorney General's
office in New Hampshire
for 10 or 15 or 20 people defrauded I
think eventually they're going to take
action right now there's nothing I can
say to that poor consumer because I
never had the money
it's horrible for the consumer is it a
pain in the neck for the Palace Theater
yes absolutely and we're deeply affected
by it it happens every single day
for the question uh it's my
understanding maybe this is for
subcommittee that that scenario would
would be illegal or at least our
consumer protection laws would apply to
that fraud scenario existing laws would
apply if if I was an attorney in the
Attorney General's office in New
Hampshire I would make the call if I
started to get calls from consumers and
I think there are a lot of them
consumers that have been I think it's
fraudible I guess um if someone has a
little bit of experience about the
consumer protection act uh the question
would be is
um have an almost standing Vivid I
assume they're not a New Hampshire
entity no I don't think so and they
don't have any brick and mortar in New
Hampshire probably not so the question
is has any
reseller in New Hampshire had been a
problem not that I know of right and
that's really the fundamental problem
going to be the enforcement yeah okay
oh representative Michael here thank you
Mr chairman just a quick question the
guy with four tickets outside your
theater selling the two extra ones
because his friends didn't show up is
that legal in New Hampshire or illegal
um scalping I never complained because
it never bothered us I was just happy
they came
um honestly I do not know
uh no we do not have a ticking scalping
law in New Hampshire
that's the last time I have seen you at
all right thank you very much thank you
Mr chairman I appreciate it thank you
representing Nashua Center for the Arts
thank you Mr chairman um still morning
good morning
my name is Peter Lally I'm the president
of spectacle live and uh we have uh
venue operations in New Hampshire
Massachusetts and Rhode Island in New
Hampshire we operate
uh the Colonial Theater in Laconia as
well as the newly opened Nashville
Center for the Arts and we also do the
booking for the Flying Monkey in
Plymouth New Hampshire uh and I'd like
to uh commend Senator Chanley and those
sponsors of the bill for this uh this
approach I won't repeat some of the uh
endorsements and information that we're
given already other than to say that uh
feel the same way in terms of what the
Senator's comments were in Mr Ramsey's
comments were but a couple of other uh
notes I think that the power in this and
again I think we'd all agree and those
that have given information on this
prior have said the same that it's not a
fix it's not a one it's it's not a uh
one stroke that will fix everything but
I think it offers a good uh solution and
I've been involved in uh with some
legislators in Massachusetts on some
approaches that have tried to go into
the transaction and all kinds of things
that get super complicated I think the
power here is its simplicity
and the fact that it it focuses on the
education and the disclosure of what
that transaction is about so uh
representative and your uh your example
of your Barry Manilow tickets
applaud you for that uh that
um that at least you know at least you
would be aware that that you you then as
the consumer would have the choice of
whether or not you wanted to
um to make that purchase but fully
knowing that you're not buying from an
organization that is the primary seller
uh I don't know if it's practical but to
go one step further it would be nice to
have the disclosure uh include
information on what the primary seller
is because these are real issues that we
deal with
um day in and day out a couple of uh
notes on
um the loss of income it is consumer
nightmare as Mr Ramsey noted but there
are a couple of other things that go
directly into a direct loss of income
one is uh that it locks up inventory
that we would otherwise be getting uh
revenue for I can give you an example uh
of tickets being sold on a secondary
Market site we found out about that
through our ticketing company refunded
those uh original purchasers
um but those tickets were were uh
because it was they were transacted on a
stolen credit card those that bought on
the secondary market then showed up to
our sold out show we as the venue are
then a never going to get we either we
have a choice we can either never
realize that Revenue because now we've
canceled those tickets but we know those
people we don't know who those people
are that bought the ticket they're on
our way to their to our theater
um so we can either a just not resell
those tickets we've given the money back
and and when those consumers show up put
them in their seats uh even though they
they've purchased fraudulent tickets or
B resell those tickets which is our
contractual obligation to the artist uh
and then tell the people that showed up
that night that I'm sorry you purchased
tickets that were originally purchased
with a stolen credit card they would
have no way of knowing that so we are in
a terrible uh bind on that secondly in
terms of
um
the ability of these secondary Market
sites to promote themselves they do so
very effectively on Google AdWords and
other advertising platforms we spend a
significant thousands of dollars a year
of our own uh for our own Google ads in
order to just be in the mix so that when
someone does search our ad shows up next
to theirs and we hope that they find
their way towards the primary seller so
we're just playing combat against their
advertising with our advertising dollars
because as you probably all know the the
sponsored search in Google is going is
showing up before the organic search so
there's definitely a direct loss uh
there another comment on Vivid Seats if
you search Vivid Seats lawsuits instead
of just Vivid Seats you will see that
there have been class action suits by
both Pennsylvania and the United Kingdom
which is where that company is based uh
this is not a nice player in the
marketplace uh by any means and has been
had action against it on a number of uh
a number of occasions
um and and a last comment on the
enforcement
um yes it's difficult
um but I think that that shouldn't stop
this uh this Committee in this body from
from pursuing this I think it is another
tool that allows us to forward the
education of those that are purchasing
tickets and and allowing the consumer to
make the choice and I think again that's
where you've got uh something you're on
to something here and in its Simplicity
of just informing the consumer that they
are not buying from the primary and they
may be then uh because we run into this
all the time where people just didn't
know that they weren't buying from us we
try to do that we promote that whenever
we have a show that goes on sale we have
language in each of those announcements
to uh tell people to go directly to our
sites and giving those addresses so that
we try to combat that as much as we can
but we're up against some powerful
adversaries who are trying to you know
work it the other way against us
um so that at least those that uh you
know we we hear time and time again from
consumers that are or they say well I
wish I knew it looked like your site I
did how was I to know uh or they'd go
through with the transaction and buy a
ticket for four or five times what it
was and they do buy it and then they get
angry at us for for selling it how can
you sell tickets at that much money it's
like well no it's a third of the price
if you had gone uh Gone directly to our
website it is the information empowering
the consumer with the information
um is really the power of it and it
doesn't restrict the sale it doesn't try
to control the price and I've seen like
I said in Massachusetts there's some
legislation being considered that is
getting way into the Weeds on pricing
and
um
so on and so forth and that gets really
complicated
um this is uh empowers the consumer to
know uh whether or not they are
purchasing directly from the source and
that those uh organizations that are
taking the Financial Risk and uh the
ones that own those tickets originally
and are contractually obligated via
their contracts with producers and
artists to Steward them in a certain way
so I applaud the approach uh again agree
that it's not a fix for everything but I
think it takes a very sensible approach
to informing the consumer about a very
venues
venue are the venues the only um place
of where you can buy a ticket for the
venue or do contract with
other companies to help sell your ticket
we have a software licensing contract
with a ticketing system so we're the
ones who are selling the ticket we
control that transaction we're the
recipient of the funds when that and the
steward of those funds when those uh
when that transaction happens so we do
have a a software contract just like you
know you'd license a word processor or
anything else but yes we are the seller
and and have full control of that
transaction that wouldn't be
Ticketmaster now would it be it is etix
it is not Ticketmaster so it's a
different one a similar similar yeah you
know there's many many different types
of um uh platforms Ticketmaster being
the the most uh famous or inFAMOUS uh
and uh that's uh the the uh the software
that we use is called e-ticket okay all
right representative
thank you Mr just quickly on uh line
nine page two
I just want to understand number three
there if if you could explain what that
means and and sure absolutely so
oftentimes
um
a reseller
will go on to when you go onto their
website you might see the opportunity to
buy a ticket in balcony section F and uh
there's no specifics on the the seat
beyond that General location and often
there's language in there that'll also
say well we're going to try to get you
section F we're not quite sure but if
you read really the fine print which is
nowhere near 14 point font that's often
saying we're going to get you a ticket
we think we're going to get you balcony
section F and that's what we're selling
you what's happening is they don't own
the tickets the reseller doesn't own the
tickets at that point so they'll like
they're good at Marketing Online they
will get that consumer to transact
initially for three four x the base the
face ticket price
uh have that money in hand and then go
to our site and buy those tickets
because they know that we had a bunch of
inventory left in a balcony section F
that they monitored so that they can
then buy from the primary send those
tickets to the consumer uh and and
what's called the lift retain the lift
the problem with that besides that you
know the ticket price is now 4X what it
should have been is that we don't have
any relationship with that consumer we
don't know that that we just know it's
been sold on our system
we can often detect accounts that are
that are doing this but that's uh not
often easy but sometimes possible
um so that transaction is now a step
removed and that consumer thinking they
bought from us actually bought uh from a
company that looked and and sounded a
okay representative purcelli then
represent post
thank you
on page two uh line one
I think there's a verb missing reselling
tickets to an event or performance
seems to me like there's something
missing unless the seller accomplishes
the following
is my first question and then I have a
quick follow-up
we will go through this in this
subcommittee so so it would be this
disclosure would be effective if we
could influence the websites actually
adhere to these disclosures so wouldn't
in your opinion would it be very
difficult to try to get these websites
that come and go to follow these very
specific system type requirements I
don't think it would be easy but I think
it's a
it's worth I think that the the the
education piece is important the
enforcement piece is difficult but I
also think that it wouldn't be just up
to the consumer to enforce I think that
uh in our case we have three different
venues that we we have a relationship
with in this in this uh state two of
which we are the primary seller
um you know it may be up to us to have
you know or or a group of us that are I
know that was the case in in um in
Pennsylvania with a class action suited
was from the consumer side not the venue
side with with Vivid Seats that was
effective and settled
um so I don't I I think it's a long
battle I also think and and um have
shared this approach with
um representative Gordon in
Massachusetts who is uh pursuing trying
to find a solution to have some uh some
teeth in in some of the the legislation
being considered there I think it's got
to be you got to start somewhere and and
this is a huge problem for consumers
it's a huge problem for the the the Arts
industry and and for the live
entertainment industry
um I don't think it's easy to get them
to do that but
um it's a lot harder if we don't have
the uh the legislation passed um and
there are domestic sites as well Vivid
Seats is one that's based in the UK but
there are a lot of other sites
um and there are a lot there are a
number of secondary sites that do try to
play by the StubHub is one that does
have a a better reputation than others
and has made an effort to follow
different
um
uh different laws and regulations that
that they're uh subject to so I think
there is some there will be some
adoption by those that are trying to
play in the secondary Market space which
is a multi-billion dollar industry
um and there are those players it's not
all Vivid Seats it's not all fraud it is
a lot of legitimate companies taking
advantage of the
the pricing inefficiencies in the live
entertainment Market you've got a a an
industry that is different from most and
that we have fixed Supply so when you
have we can't add more seats we've got
the capacity that we have so the only
Flex in that is price when the demand
outstrips Supply so there's a lot of
companies that play in that secondary
space that do try to play by the rules
and I think that they would adopt this
there are a lot that would be harder to
enforce that wouldn't but like I said I
think it's a sensible approach that that
um you know starts somewhere
and representative post
Mr chairman and thank you for
monthly how many people come in that
have these fraudulent tickets it's hard
for us to track because there are many
occasions where someone will buy that
second ticket on the secondary Market
receive the ticket come to the
performance
um and never knew that they didn't buy
on the primary on the primary sale that
they
they paid x amount they went to the show
and and that was it
um
they never had the opportunity to know
that they weren't or probably never knew
that they weren't buying from that
primary source or that they paid a
significant amount over so we do track
it most of the time when we're when we
find out about it it's because there's
been uh our partner ticketing company
e-tix has a fraud department and often
they'll tell us hey we've seen
this account with these characteristics
be associated with some fraudulent
transactions heads up you should look
for a b or c or secondly we're dealing
with someone night of the show at the
box office that has uh an issue it's not
often that they're simply selling a
fraudulent ticket it's often that the
transaction itself was
um
opaque in terms of of who they were
buying from and meant to be it was a a
transaction based on misrepresentation
of who they were buying from
so just follow up for the question so
with that what you're saying is you lose
the money from the ticket if the people
don't come and say
if you know well we received
we will have received the funds from the
secondary market so we were made you
know we we would have received they
would have bought that ticket
um where we run into problems is if that
ticket we had an issue where a number of
years ago where
um
tickets were being purchased with with
stolen credit cards
um so that and then being dumped into
secondary market sales platforms at half
price because they weren't paying for
the ticket in the first place 50 is
better than nothing and it's all so that
what we ended up with was
people's whose credit cards were stolen
initiated a charge back with the credit
card company so we lost the money in
that case
um and then the consumer showed up with
a ticket that was canceled so in in that
case that was earlier I was describing
the kind of that a b scenario do we just
deny the consumer when they show up at
the door do we lose the money
so often most of the times we are
receiving what we put the ticket on sale
for the lift so the the three four x the
The Base ticket price that uh was paid
we don't participate in that's a whole
other and I think that's kind of the the
some of the power in in of this approach
is that it isn't focusing on that lift
that's a whole other
um a whole other ball of wax that that
gets you know extremely complicated I
think
but just the disclosure piece of saying
consumer you are not buying from the
original source of this even though you
may think you are so there's just no
there the best they that the secondary
markets can do is look to represent
themselves as closely to a primary
ticket sale uh sale as they can
um and being able to disclose and inform
the public that that's not the
transaction they're about to enter into
uh I think is the is a powerful approach
thank you very much thanks again I have
one more card left Salvador pizio from
good afternoon everybody I would say
good morning but we're past that point
now so uh my name is Sal purzio with the
capital Center for the Arts uh I am
going to be very brief today because my
two colleagues did a fantastic job
outlining some of the issues that have
been presented before you today
um I will highlight though that the
capital Center this year alone and I'm
talking about from September through now
has lost almost twenty thousand dollars
in ticket sales as a result of we were
victim this year of the credit card uh
scams that have been going on uh stolen
credit cards are used to purchase
tickets for events and much like was
said before the consumer came to our
venue looking for those seats but we had
no idea that those people were even
purchase tickets from us because those
tickets had already been refunded by the
credit card company because they were
fraudulent purchases so a we were out
the money from those tickets unless we
were informed far enough in advance to
resell them and then B we have a whole
host of people coming to our spaces
screaming in our faces that they spent
three four hundred dollars for tickets
and they're only recourses to go back to
Vivid Seats and or other ticket
companies and try to get their refunds
from them
we have reached out to these companies
time and time again with no results
we've asked them to at least disclose to
us who the people were that bought the
fraudulent tickets so that we could try
to reach out to them again directly and
try to make some sort of recourse even
though it's not our responsibility to do
so but it is our reputations on the line
so that is one of the specific examples
I wanted to highlight to this committee
here the other two points I really
wanted to make sure and this is a bit of
a kind of an education on a piece of our
business here is when we book a show
part of that contract is specifically
designed in that contract there were
specific language in there that says we
are licensing the tickets from the
musician or the artist or whoever these
are the specific contract stated prices
the number of tickets that can be sold
at each individual price so when I see
third-party sites going and doing this
in my opinion it's a violation of that
contract of which they're not party to
but still it's a direct violation of
that contract the other thing I think is
incredibly important to know for this
this body and in general this is the
education we're trying to tell people is
when you buy a ticket it's a seat
license it's not a piece of property so
much like I heard in our in my Senate
testimony somebody had countered with
well if I buy a car I can turn around
and sell it on the used car market for
wherever I want
a car is your personal piece of property
when you buy a ticket to a show you're
essentially buying the right to go sit
for that per certain period of time and
listen to that artist's intellectual
property a more accurate comparison
would be I paid for Netflix so I'm going
to go down the street to the movie
theater and show Netflix movies and
charge people for it that's a more
accurate representation of what you're
doing when you buy a ticket and then
turn around and sell it on the third
party Market
it's always gonna there's always going
to be the guy outside of the the venue
holding you know with the trench coat
maybe not a trench coat maybe it's a
windbreaker whatever selling tickets
this is a much more sophisticated
operation and like was said before it's
become a multi-billion dollar operation
um and it's affecting us it's I mean
when you when you want you asked uh
earlier how often is this happening we
are getting this at every single show
now somebody's showing up that spent two
three four hundred dollars for tickets
that were fifty sixty dollars
so
they are to the points that they were
saying before they're spending money on
Google ads we get the non-for-profit
Google megaphone thing that tries to
compete with it but we're a small
non-for-profit in Concord New Hampshire
I can't compete on an advertising scale
with Vivid Seats in StubHub they're
spending multi-million dollars to buy
Google ads that outpace us so if you
were to look at if you were to Google
right now Marshall Tucker Band Capital
Center for the Arts I guarantee you
Vivid Seats etix StubHub are going to be
in the mix with us right there sometimes
we show up number one sometimes we don't
but the problem is is the consumer pays
for it and then we pay for it and lost
Revenue
so those are that's uh what everything
else was pretty well said by my
colleagues so I don't want to keep
reiterating the same points but I'm
happy to answer any questions I
appreciate them representative
thank you Mr chair
um thanks for taking my question and
before every performance is there an
opportunity for yourself or somebody
else that works at the Capitol to
explain or you know do a a justice so
not all yeah we have the language on our
website and every time I do a Curtain
Speech I literally say to the audience
please buy your tickets from ccanh.com
because I can guarantee the price and I
can guarantee the ticket's real if you
buy it from anybody else I can't
representative Yemen
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking our questions and of course
realize we're going pretty long here
um
I just I'm curious from the your
business perspective if these other
third-party ticket sellers are a benefit
to your business do are you putting
butts in seats that you might otherwise
uh would not have if it weren't for this
extended advertising reach of these
third-party uh ticket sellers no because
I they're not advertising on your
traditional media like social media or
anything like that what they're doing is
they're just paying Google ads to get
when you do a search ad so it's not
anything that's increasing our
attendance in fact I would say the
opposite I think they're parasitic to
our right it goes back to the question
that representative Gibbs in terms of
the hotels yeah you know uh you know
when I stay at a hotel I I know which ho
what the I know I have to keep going
down the list till I find the actual
properties email address absolutely
because uh their actual you know the web
page because because bookings is always
a top yeah but this is always going to
be and the other ones are always going
to be a top and hotels.com whatever so
you gotta you gotta you gotta be patient
and go down the list and uh it used to
be nice they used to have a line Google
used to have a line yeah it was above
and then they got rid of it because they
make money on it too I mean I can tell
you right now if you you can actually go
on Ticketmaster and buy tickets to
events at the capital Center we're not a
Ticketmaster venue and they call it the
reselling tickets location but what they
do is that same thing they use Bots to
figure out on our ticketing platform
what seats are available they don't even
buy them and if somebody wants to buy a
ticket through them then that bot will
go and buy the ticket through us
and the thing I think the important
thing to take away from all this too is
that again we enter into a contract with
an artist
and any of those markups any of the lift
that was said before the artist is not
participating in any of that and we have
specific lifts for VIP and all that sort
of stuff because people are paying to
see intellectual property in person and
if they're not participating in any of
that additional Revenue then it's a loss
to them and a loss to us who put out the
guarantees and the we take all the risk
when we have an artist come into a space
so it's it's a double whammy for us now
look I don't think this I think this
bill is on the 20 yard line as far as we
were where we need to go as an industry
um but it's a great first step in
educating the the consumer that you're
not buying from us
so we this bill will go to a
subcommittee and you've given me a great
idea for the solution to your problem so
we'll take it off then thank you I
appreciate all your time thank you very
much all right so we've closed the
public hearing finally on 201 uh I can
see uh uh nobody signed the blue sheet
and on online we had five in support
three of which were co-sponsors and two
people opposed I'm close to hearing and
I'm I'm assuming this next one is going
to be a quickie so I think we're gonna
we're gonna go we're going forward with
and
okay
so uh
again yeah you're gonna
sponsor for Gannon who's gonna yeah okay
say thank you
okay yeah Oh Maya they're okay Maya
Harvey okay
all right well good morning chairman
hunt members of the Commerce Committee
I'm Maya Harvey and I'm here to
introduce Senate Bill 66 on behalf of
Senator Bill Gannon the Bill's Prime
sponsor
in 1932 Federal home loan Banks or
fhlvs were chartered by Congress
they are cooperatively structured and
members member-owned wholesale banks
that provide reliable access to low-cost
funding and liquidity to support Housing
Finance and Community Development
banks credit unions and insurance
companies located in New England are
eligible to voluntarily join as members
their interactions with banks and credit
unions are governed by federal law but
insurance is under the jurisdiction of
the state
Senate Bill 66 aims to align state and
federal law to bring parity to fhlbs for
banks credit unions and insurance
companies
this bill would modify Insurance
insolvency regulation Provisions
specifically related to stays and
this bill ensures that insurance
companies are treated similar to
depository institutions thus allowing
them to borrow at the cheapest possible
rate so savings are passed Downstream to
Consumers
Senate Bill 66 received unanimous
support from the Senate Commerce
Committee and passed on the consent
calendar
I will defer questions to the industry
experts here in support of Senate Bill
66 but if you do have specific questions
for Senator Gannon I can make sure he
gets you an answer
Senator Gannon thanks you for your
consideration and support of Senate Bill
66. thank you
and we thank you very much
okay uh chair is going to call on Keith
Walsh from the federal Home Loan Bank of
Boston
and I apologize for this
ironically I had a fairly well time for
the two bills but then this bill got
lost in the in the Hinterlands of the
computer world and if it wasn't for
meeting you guys in the hallway we might
never have gotten it scheduled so I went
chased it down and that's why I snuck it
in here but obviously
um the sneaky end didn't work as well as
I would have liked
me
so yeah you hit the little button there
there you go red light's good yeah red
is good here thank you committee chair
uh hunt and the rest of the committee
for having me here to testify in support
of sb66 Miss Hardy did an excellent job
of uh summarizing a little bit about the
home loan bank and and the bill
um I'll try to keep these remarks brief
just to reiterate
um we'll first introduce myself I'm
Keith Walsh I Am The General Counsel and
a senior vice president at the Home Loan
Bank of Boston Home Loan Bank of Boston
is one of 11 Regional Home Loan Banks
chartered by Congress as a Depression
era measure in 1932 so we just
celebrated our 90-year history
uh banks credit unions insurance
companies and Community Development
financial institutions located in New
England are eligible to be members of
the Home Loan Bank
we currently have 33 members in New
Hampshire and they're a mix of banks
we're government-sponsored Enterprises
and and cooperatively owned meaning
we're owned by our members those banks
credit unions and insurance companies
and we only do business with our members
we're wholesale Banks we don't we don't
lend to individuals and consumers we
lend to banks credit unions and
insurance companies
to access our liquidity members pledge
collateral by Statute by federal statute
we're only able to lend on a secured
basis and that collateral is typically
in the form of mortgage loans and
the home loan Banks because we're
government-sponsored Enterprises are
able to access liquidity in in the
global Capital markets on advantageous
terms and we pass that benefit on to our
members by making low-cost loans to them
um that's government-sponsored
Enterprise status also means we can
access funds in the global Capital
markets throughout all economic Cycles
whether it was the Great Depression
pandemic or more recently the the March
banking crisis where two two
high-profile bank failures created some
instability in the banking industry and
the Home Loan Bank stepped up by raising
records amount record amounts of funding
to meet the needs of our bank and credit
union members
the home loan Banks of Boston also does
a number of things in the community in
in this region
we set aside at least 10 percent of our
net income for affordable housing
initiatives both rental and home
ownership
we have two down payment assistance
programs for the low to moderate income
families
we have a program called jobs for New
England that makes subsidized loans
available to our bank and credit union
members that they can in turn make loans
to small businesses in New England to
create or preserve jobs in the region
and in 2023 we'll launch a special
purpose credit program that will provide
down payment assistance to people of
color in an effort to bridge the racial
homeownership Gap
so with all that as background about the
bank
the specifics in sb66 says Miss Hardy
alluded to are designed to create parity
between federal laws applicable to your
your New Hampshire Banks and credit
unions and state insurance laws which
apply to the New Hampshire insurance
companies
under Federal banking laws the home loan
bank is afforded protections that enable
that that don't make us subject to a
state period or any claw back risk with
respect to our collateral if a bank or
credit union were to fail
we do not have similar protections under
New Hampshire's Insurance code and and
that is exactly what SB 66 would be
designed to introduce them to the
insurance code
although the subject matter of sb66 is
an insurance company receivership there
I can tell you that as far as I'm aware
there's no imminent risk to the
insurance industry in New Hampshire or
anywhere else in New England
instead sb66 admittedly addresses an
extremely rare what-if scenario
but as a heavily regulated financial
institution the the home loan bank is
expected to plan for those exceedingly
rare what-if scenarios
and the certainty provide provided by SB
66 to the home loan Banks does just that
by ensuring that we could continue to
provide liquidity to our insurance
company members in New Hampshire right
up to the point of receivership and and
not have to have concerns about the
availability of our collateral
I can tell you that similar legislation
has become law already in 24 States
we're pursuing similar Legislation
during this legislative session in both
Massachusetts and Vermont
um resource constraints alone we might
have been in all six New England states
this session and and we'll probably be
in those other three next year
so in closing I thank the committee for
their consideration of the bill and
stand by for any questions you may have
um hopefully you have a copy of your
testimony because the clerk would I I
think I handed it to them okay great
making its way around yep
um yeah just make sure I understand
what's the difference between the
Federal Reserve
and and you guys are you part do you get
your money from the Federal Reserve also
or are you we're not the government uh
the federal home loan Banks um our our
government-sponsored Enterprises who are
who are member owned so we're privately
owned and and we're owned by our members
who are the banks credit unions and
insurance companies so we are privately
held institutions not the federal
government so are you owned by other
Banks or owned by we're owned by the
bank's credit unions and insurance
companies in New England okay we
currently have 427 banks credit unions
and insurance companies that are our
shareholders
okay all right good question all right
representative Terry thank you
so um if you've since you've been in
existence since 1932 and it sounds like
the structure the members have been
in place since 1932 that is the banks
the credit unions and the insurance
companies
why now with respect to this particular
issue as opposed to 10 20 30 or 40 50
years ago
good question and the I would say
although insurance companies have been
eligible eligible to be members of the
Home Loan Bank since 1932 only about in
the 90s early 2000s did we really see an
uptick in insurance company membership
and with that uptick in in membership
our regulator became focused on the
disparities between how we how we how
the law treats our business with our
insurance company members and how the
law treats our business with banks and
credit unions and I think that those 24
states that have passed this legislation
in 2010 that might have been one or two
this has really been an effort over the
last decade
um to pass this similar legislation and
all of the the states uh in in the
United States and
we're making some Headway another
question just to be clear the
eligibility has been in place since 1932
but it's been more recently than
insurance companies have uh a greater
involvement and that's why this issue
has emerged correct thank you got it
okay representation
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony and taking questions my
pleasure uh in in the previous uh
presenter uh Miss Harvey she used the
term that I'm not familiar with I
thought maybe I'd ask you
um it's stays and voidable transfers uh
that seemed to be significant in what
we're talking about here if you could
just explain that correct so uh stay
think of it um another term you might
see used in in certain States laws it's
like an injunction so a stay would mean
if an insurance company in New Hampshire
entered a receivership they'd basically
be a pens down everyone Full Stop on
exercising your rights as to that
insurance company whether it's a
policyholder a secured creditor like the
bank
um or any other creditor
um there's a there's a corollary in
federal bankruptcy law called the
automatic stay so I think that's why
it's it's often referred to that the
avoidable preference I would put those
broadly in the category of clawback risk
uh the risk is that once a a company
enters receivership or bankruptcy it's
the risk to you as a as a secured
creditor that somebody's going to come
back try to claw back your collateral
you're interested in that in that
collateral those are the two points that
are being addressed by SB 66 with
respect to New Hampshire insurance
companies and for which the banks the
federal home loan Banks already have
ironically the only Bank we've insurance
company we've ever had was actually
okay great thank you very much thanks
hi my name is Doug Bartlett I'm the
director of financial regulations for
the insurance department
and um
just I'm here to say that we uh in
support of the bill
we have 10 insurers that actually use
this
um and and I didn't hear Keith
say this maybe he did but they they buy
stock
in the home loan bank and that and and
so these 10 companies that buy stock are
eligible to uh to borrow money
um
we only have one company that has
actually borrowed money that still owes
some
uh and and like he says it's a liquidity
thing we had a one of our companies that
wrote Federal crop insurance
and you know by the time they get the
premium it's like a year and a half
after they wrote the policy and they uh
they did use it uh to um for liquidity
that company was bought by AIG and they
don't use it anymore but uh so those
those are the two instances I know that
uh
uh New Hampshire companies have actually
borrowed but it is some large lines of
credit there are three Liberty companies
um
what I'd call capacity to borrow if they
levels the playing field for the
insurance companies yeah close to okay
any questions then okay
representative so the department I I
take it the department does not have any
concerns with this bill and you're fully
in support of it yes you're fine yes
okay up to this point though there have
okay thank you
nope
all right Tina thank you very much thank
you okay so uh we will close the public
hearing and Senate Bill 66 all right
that means we've heard all our bills
committee members we've heard everything
so far we'll start with an uh liquor
laws this afternoon liquor bills this
afternoon and then next week
um we will do insurance and banking I'm
gonna decide which one to do the morning
Wednesday the Third
so I need to be somewhere in the
afternoon okay so the morning so we'll
do business in the morning is that all
right yes okay business in the morning
Insurance in the afternoon next
Wednesday
other than that
in this subcommittee
two sick walls hunt Burrows Gibbs
okay
great
all right so first one I have here
Senate Bill 21 relative to the due date
and delivery of monthly reports and fees
I don't think anybody have a problem
okay so this was Senate Bill 21
and this was to remove the reporting
okay
all right
uh
okay
so what I do is I Circle my name through
um
and
um okay all those in all those in favor
about to pass raise your hand one two
three four representative Gibbs
sorry in spite of what the agenda says
I'm not on the liquor subcommittee I'm
on the insurance company I've just
reminded right yes so representative
Sullivan is on it that's right that's
right
they got the wrong print out I was
uh
oh that was yeah but that's my other
patch it's like six zero
and then to say any discussion
did you say uh no no nobody had any
machine
what are you asking for good afternoon
yeah that's right I got it I got
something so we're all right okay
all right
uh Sun pill 37 establishing commissioned
to study hospitality and tourism
Mr chairman I do have a comment on this
one if I may okay thank you
um uh there's a list of uh proposed
um members of the commission yep and it
seems to me that it would be useful to
add someone who is a worker in the
hospitality industry
um I don't think very many of them are
unionized so I don't know that we could
go about it that way although I'd be
perfectly comfortable who who what
Association do they have to get them
appointed uh I don't know but I think it
would be worth finding out and including
an amendment
um the amendment could start with just a
representative or or simply a worker in
the hospitality industry and then the
chair of the commission could find out
um uh who to get a recommendation from
however if you would like I will inquire
uh okay you can inquire
um we don't I mean I this is just a
study commission other than that adding
a member I don't know any more than that
but I I'm sorry I couldn't hear you I'm
just saying just it's only a study
commission so uh that would be the only
amendment you know otherwise in terms of
having the subcommittee we're not we
have any strong opinions when
representative
Commission
you're on the study yeah
yeah the alcohol tourism Commission
right a long time ago right no I was
saying yeah you did talk about the study
this is a commission this is not a study
committee you're on a special committee
yeah that is studying the commissions or
it is I that's why I asked him okay if
he would be willing to be on this and
you know be the first member and he said
yes
so it meets the criteria yeah so I'm
okay with an OTP on this
I don't think it's needed it's not a big
it's not a big Rule and I think it's I
think it's good I think they can all get
together with having
establishing a commission
right I'm curious why we need it if UNH
has a thing that apparently the Senate
I don't know I mean UNH already has a
yeah he's a professor there okay I want
to do it I mean but UNH has a program on
this I don't get why we need a committee
on how to educate people when UNH
supposedly is doing it and
maybe just needs to market the program
better
I mean I I'm generally supportive of
study committee so if we want to do it
that's fine I'm not saying there's a big
cost if we pass it but I'm I'm I was I
I mean it's just you know all right Mr
chairman yeah can I speak on this please
sure thank you are you a co-sponsor uh
am I no Senator Innis is the only only
sponsor okay but the thing is uh I was
on the Alcohol tourism Commission
and uh we got a lot done but we never
had a final report
um what it says no we never did was that
but that was about the signage right you
get to get get you guys to get allow you
uh to put them on the blue signs
for directional because there was a yeah
that was Transportation had a rule
against but it never happened or
something and and on the highway so so
that was that was a well-focused uh
study committee yeah this one is you
know under a examine existing
hospitality and tourist programs and
community colleges and universities take
a look at the curriculum that's all it
says and make sure that they are
doing programs which do focus on tourism
that's all it says
well
somebody thought it was important to
make sure that we are
focusing on the tourism stuff in college
because tourism is big bucks for the
State of New Hampshire yeah but that's a
cricket that's a college curriculum
issue there is one it might and there
was one in UNH I mean my son went to
Denver University of Denver and they had
it had a Hospitality program and
okay
so you're gonna make an itl motion
okay all those in favor say aye
me two three four five six
uh Mr chairman so if it's going to be
IPL then my in my proposal to inquire is
pointless that is true and
but we did write that you thought it was
lacking that position yes but if we're
not going to deposit then I won't bother
inquiring yeah that's a good point good
idea
okay
all right last but not least relative to
product labeling and information guide
requirements for cannabis products and
prohibition of the sale of hemp products
containing certain levels of THC uh so
the only thing I see is we need we need
an amendment
Chris
Dean uh we're going to need an amendment
uh to make it point three
yeah
Speak now or forevermore hold your peace
in terms of in terms of the Liquor
Commission that um that you know their
job is to enforce the law and obviously
they're already in there
I I have a question
um
who so right now the Liquor Commission
doesn't regulate like uh other stores
that sell like CBD stores so if they're
selling these things as well who will
regulate that because that seems like an
obvious loophole in this law
um
commission does go into
most of the stores that sell
s
right okay if they sell tobacco or
vaping equipment so if they only sold
just CBD
they don't go in there I don't know if
those stores exist but they do it seems
like an obvious loophole that would be a
well good luck I do remember the first
time I saw a CBD was I was at tandy's
and the woman across there and she said
it was a beauty beauticians salon and
she had a CBD sign in the window
yeah
and they would sell CBD
so like are there is there one of those
in the state or is there a hundred of
those I don't think I know but I I don't
even know I don't even know if she's
still in business but I remember whether
they're I mean terms of those type of
people who are selling CBD
um they're going to be more
it's a health conscious type item so so
I don't think I don't think they're
going to be into into Delta this Delta
thing is more more of a uh
uh what I would call an off-premise
licensee
you're saying that you think that the
people who are in CBD aren't probably
selling these cartridges that we're
concerned about is that what you're
saying right right but yeah but if they
were then that you know law enforcement
in that Community could
charge them to or get them to shut it
down
so if somebody discovered it then it
happened I mean it's the old classic
somebody drop a dime on them right right
so I'm sure you think if there's another
I'm sure those atcs will drop dimes on
people if they see
that
yes representative walls thank you
is the does the Liquor Commission need
to be trained as to specifically what
products are going to be
null you know not prohibited
and can and against current resources
I I I would say they'll have to get up
to speed yeah
so for the question further question
so when this gets passed uh
in The Liquor Commission agents go into
convenience stores of which there are
many and find these products do they
confiscate them
you know or uh because if you're relying
upon the the
convenience store people to do it I
doubt they will be like they would come
in and tell the store to get it off the
shelf
so it's not really
being destroyed or one of my favorite
stories about my visits to the Liquor
Commission office every once in a while
it was at one point in time
there was a
video poker machine sitting in the back
room and I go oh what's that doing here
he says well
they're illegal and
he they found it was in Manchester you
know it was a you know situation but he
goes Nobody everybody looked at each
other who whose job is it to get rid of
this thing
and so the commission took it and it sat
there I assume they finally destroyed it
at some point but but
um and They confiscated everybody sold
them on eBay
I I I would assume and knowing the
commission and I'm sure Aiden's
listening in and uh he you can you can
text me Aiden is um
that there uh
part of their mission is to educate so
yes that it once we were to pass the
statute that day would be
aware of it and they would be that if
they go into these stores and see it but
the you have to know that the what
really drives a lot of the stuff is
someone dropping a dime another rich
said that you you go into a store or I
go into a store and I see this and say
you know you get you can't sell this so
should there be additional
um verbiage on this that says that the
that the Liquor Commission will
see to it that the product is
confiscated and or destroyed I would
have to I'd have to find out from them
because otherwise they can just sell it
you know with as as our vice chair said
You know open up this
trench coat and say Hey you know that's
a good that we consider the illegal
Market yes well yes it would become
they're not selling it behind the Jack
they would be hanging out but
um well I remember in the when this
whole spice thing went down and yeah
there was a lot of them there was a
behind the Shelf under the counter
type issue and
um but in terms of so that you beg the
question if they really solved it is are
there still some
off-premise licensees uh potentially
so who knows but but this goes back to
Keith's issue is why why pass the law
against something if you really can't
truly make enforce it and the argument
the other side is you gotta you know you
got to do something you got to get it on
the books you get you do have some
effort you know to make it illegal and
make it clear it's illegal yes but if
you if you that you know that yeah the
the problem with any law
this is only as good as you know
somebody's aware of some breaking the
law and can enforce it
Danielle from The Liquor Commission was
supposed to be here but she was out sick
today oh she's trying to get somebody to
take her place to be
make sure that some of the Liquor
Commission will be here yeah I would
like an answer as to what happens to the
product
that when what actually happens what
happens to the product
you know if this is enacted within what
is it 60 days right then yeah they'll
just ship it to some other vendor
somebody out of some other state that
doesn't have a law would you know that
so we have tried to have this
conversation with the folks from The
Liquor Commission my understanding is
that they would initially
make them aware that this is not legal
to sell in New Hampshire perhaps suggest
that they ship it back to the
manufacturer or something like that and
that if they were continuing to sell the
product then then there would be
enforcement with regard to other
businesses that might be selling these
process these products I don't think any
of us envisioned this bill as a
comprehensive 100 percent solution these
products are available mail order so
there's nothing New Hampshire can do to
stop somebody from ordering it from
Texas and having it delivered
what this bill would do is make it very
clear that New Hampshire law does not
authorize the sale of these products so
it would allow enforcement my
understanding at the licensees we've
already mentioned and what a few states
have done recently the Connecticut
attorney general's office did a
Statewide Crackdown I believe they sent
cease and desist letters to businesses
that were selling these products and
then any that were still doing so as of
a certain date they actually rated them
and confiscated the products so that may
be an option for New Hampshire once it's
clear there will be some training would
be updated for all the enforcement but
he says at the end if it is an illegal
item they would need a court order
to destroy it the evidence
so they they could come is that I assume
either that means they can confiscate it
and then hold it and wait till they get
the court order to
it's a whole Brave New World
Mr chairman doing it this way but let's
see what happens his response okay uh
but at least
um this bill would help get it off the
counter where teenagers are picking it
up
um I mean that's that's really the most
at the end of the day we're taking care
of this this loophole that's in our
statute he says the answer is yes
that that's what would happen so they
would be able to confiscate it
but then they would have to thank you
court order to destroy the evidence
that's that
protocol and evidence anyway right so I
assume that's what happened to that
video poker machine nothing new Oh
either that somebody took it home and
okay so John is is there going to be an
amendment to this guy I hope yes so we
have to have an amendment so we can have
a uh straw vote uh for ought to pass
representative petusic
and
representative Burroughs seconds
that moves 0.03 to 0.3
yes that would that need to be
correction
so Aiden tells me that the machine was
steamrolled
[Laughter]
okay great
thanks everybody yes any discussion all
those uh in favor about the password
with Amendment raise your hands four
all right